wer libyen hört denkt zwangsläufig an
überfüllte flüchtlingsboote auf ihrem
weg über das mittelmeer richtung europa
es gibt aber viele gründe viele wichtige
gründe sich mit der entwicklung in
libyen genauer auseinanderzusetzen
[Musik]
libyen war eines der ersten länder das
2011 und den umbrüchen im arabischen
raum erfasst wurde dafür der langzeit
diktator wurde nach monatelangen kämpfen
gestürzt und es gab es versuche hier
eine übergangsregierung zu bilden und
das land zu transformieren
leider ist das gescheitert 2014 kam es
dann zu einem bürgerkrieg mühsam ist man
aus dem heraus gekommen
wir hatten zwei regierungen heute haben
wir eine gemeinsame regierung aber im
prinzip ist das land noch immer in zwei
regionen ost und west geteilt und wir
haben einen großen einfluss bereich der
stämme mit kämpfen untereinander im
süden des landes
warum ist der herr libyen gerade das
europäische und österreichische
perspektive so wichtig für strategische
faktoren sind hier zumindest anzuführen
erster punkt internationale sicherheit
im land im chaos ist entlang der
unsicherheit
es erlaubt extremisten kriminellen
terroristen sich festzusetzen um ihr
handwerk zu treiben uns auf dauer ist es
hier ein stabilität
sie hat mir ein kleines beispiel 2015
terroristen des islamischen staates
haben sich in orten an der küste für
längere zeit festsetzen können
zweiter bereich regionale sicherheit ein
instabiles land erzeugt automatisch
unsicherheit auch nach außen die grenzen
können nicht gesichert werden
es gibt überschwappe effekte in die
region oder es gibt auch einfluss von
außen in das land selbst hinein
wir haben derzeit gerade ägypten die
arabischen emirate unter christen die
sich hier ganz besonders intensiv in
libyen engagiert der bereich migrations
kontrolle wurde schon angesprochen wir
müssen uns vor augen führen
90 prozent der flüchtlinge aus dem
afrikanischen raum sind über migrations
route libyen richtung europa gestartet
und der vierte bereich energiepolitisch
die europäische perspektive sehr wichtig
auf die unglaublichen ölvorkommen lügens
auch in zukunft zugreifen zu können und
andererseits sehen wir dass russland
sich ganz massiv engagiert um hier sich
in rain zu kaufen
ich interpretiere das als versucht hier
die europäische abhängigkeit von
russland einfach erhalten zu wollen
was macht die internationale
gemeinschaft um libyen auf diesem weg
der reformen und transformation zu
unterstützen
von anbeginn waren es die vereinten
nationen die hier den politischen
prozess ganz massiv unterstützt haben
was ja auch dazu geführt dass wir heute
so eine übergangsregierung haben wo alle
kräfte versammelt sind
aber eigentlich möchte libyen eine
eigene lösung haben eine libysche lösung
für libysche probleme daher auch in
kleiner ansatz von seiten der eu dass
man hier das grenzmanagement im süden
des landes verbessert das ist ganz ganz
wichtig weil er unglaublich viele
strömungen aus gesamt afrika hier nach
lybien eingehen
und wir haben auch hier eine
zusammenarbeit im bereich der
küstenwache wo es darum geht sie
aufzubauen auszubilden und auf
entsprechend auszustatten
auch hier ist die eu ganz vorne
friedenstruppe wie viele erwartet haben
internationale mit mehreren tausend gibt
es nicht sehe ich auch keine chance in
absehbarer zukunft
wie kann es daher in und mit libyen
weitergehen
libyen hat sehr gute voraussetzungen im
vergleich zu anderen über eine
streichung des ölvorkommens mehr als 70
milliarden dollar sind im ausland
eingefroren das wäre eine unglaubliche
anschubfinanzierung und lieben ist auch
die zu gestalten wie andere länder es
gibt keine sezessionistische tendenzen
eigentlich geht man von einem lüge
hinaus das wichtigste ist daher den
politischen prozess zu unterstützen und
das ist ganz wichtig dass man hier auch
die störfaktoren von außerhalb
unterbindet und wichtig ist auch die
sicherheitslage natürlich zu verbessern
weil die unglaublich vielen milizen hier
eine unsicherheit erzeugen die
ausländische investoren abschreckt
libyen hat somit gute karten für die
zukunft es braucht auch auf gute
politische spieler um die angestrebte
logische lösung für die jüdische zukunft
erzielen zu können
[Musik]